Yeah, so there's pros and cons to different labs. There's pros and cons to different testing
um, and just because we do something that is quote, quote, quote, quote, standard according to
practice and standards of care, it doesn't mean it's a perfect. So, talk to somebody today that did uh,
you know, MRI and you know, then do another test and
the MRI was just wrong. And it's just so, it's just not, nothing's perfect. So, um, uh,
you just got to weigh that out. Whole body MRIs without contrast are available to
assignment, manifold, I don't know if that's any good. I think you're talking about the
pre-nuvo test. Um, if you are, I think they're good. That's what I had done. So I did the pre-nuvo
um, if you look up pre-nuvo, I think it's PR-E-N-U-U-O. Um, there's clinics all around the country.
Now, I think there's about a dozen clinics in the United States that you could do that.
Again, the negative of that is that insurance doesn't cover that. You can schedule it.
You don't even know if you need a doctor, you know, request. You could just schedule out of their website.
But, I think they're about $20,000, but she's got to weigh out whether that's what you want to do.
I think they're good tests. We didn't have one person about a year ago on his in-call.
Didn't achieve it. She didn't like it. I can't remember who did it. I can't
remember who did it. I didn't like it. I didn't like it. Um, I did it. And I was very happy with
the results. I think they formated. I was getting much better at that time.
It's feeling way better. Um, and it showed. I mean, I just had a couple of issues with my liver.
That's a time. And um, um, I thought it went really well.
So, uh, this is 650 cash costs. So that's probably not the pre-nuvo test then. So, I don't know.
So, the benefit, um, you know, the whole body MRI without contrast, you're going to be missing
some things too. So, um, yeah, I'm not sure about, um, good, not doing it with contrast.
Again, you know, any, any test you do is going to have pros and cons. So, again, nothing is going to be
perfect. Imagine they'd be able to see everything that's going on inside your body.